es handelt sich um eine absolut
spektakuläre kosmische katastrophe mit
hilfe des nasa weltraumteleskops tests
konnte ein astronomie team jetzt sind
tod eines sterns durch ein schwarzes
loch aus nächster nähe beobachten und
das sogar schon von anfang an eine echte
premiere und dieser spektakuläre stand
und enthüllt äußerst überraschende
erkenntnisse klicks um science fiction
die gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktivität
locken und dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen schwarze
löcher bringen den tod wenn ein stern in
die nähe eines schwarzen loches gerät
wird dieser durch die änderungen
gezeitenkräfte auseinandergerissen das
schwarze loch saugt den ohne erbarmen
auf in der fachsprache ist von einem
sogenannten teile des raschen event die
rede
es kommt zu jets aus energiereichen
teilchen gas klumpen am ereignishorizont
und strahlen ausbrüchen und fest steht
der appetit von schwarzen löchern kann
gigantisch sein größtes talent materie
aufsaugen wenn es keine materie rund um
ihr schwerefeld mehr gibt warten sie
geduldig ab bis sie wieder zuschlagen
können und die enorme schwerkraft dieser
massemonster sorgt dafür dass immer
wieder nahe sterne oder gaswolken in
ihrem gravitations strudel geraten doch
bislang gelang es forschungsteams
weltweit nur einige male solch einen
spektakulären sternen tod zu beobachten
denn diese sind sehr selten schätzungen
zufolge kommen solche teile des raschen
events in einer galaxie in der größe der
milchstraße nur einmal in 10.000 bis
100.000 jahren vor eine weitere
herausforderung für die fachleute
besteht darin solch ein ereignis
rechtzeitig aufzuspüren bisher wurden
die sterne tode erst dann detektiert
wenn der strahlen ausbruch schon wieder
ab klang und der stern bereits zerstört
war doch jetzt gelang mit hilfe des nasa
teleskops tests eine sensationelle
premiere in einer 375 millionen
lichtjahre entfernten galaxie konnte
ende januar diesen jahres 2009 10 einen
heller ausbruch aufgespürt werden und
zwar fast von anfang an zunächst nahmen
die teleskope der oldschool thomas
service supernovae essen dieses
spektakuläre ereignis aufgespürt und
direkt meldung
ein anderer astronomie teams weltweit
gegeben die aufregung war groß doch so
wurde es möglich die mahlzeit des
schwarzen lochs auch in anderen
auflösungen und wellenlängen zu
beobachten schnell war klar dass das
tracing exoplanet survey satellite es
der nasa dieses ereignis perfekt ins
visier nehmen kann eigentlich eben für
exoplaneten doch in diesem fall konnte
es diesen sternen fraß durch ein
schwarzes loch beobachten doch nicht nur
das die aufnahmen ermöglichen es den
fachleuten sogar die abläufe bis zu 42
tage vor dem eigentlichen höhepunkt
zurückzuverfolgen konkret fand der helle
ausbruch am 29 10 2009 10 im zentrum
einer galaxie stadt die 375 millionen
lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nannten den sternen tod
es essen 19 bt die beobachtung dieses
ereignisses ist etwas ganz besonderes
denn bislang wurde solch eine kosmische
katastrophe noch niemals so detailliert
beobachten
das ist für die fachleute selbst ein
echter grund zum feiern dazu der us
astronom patrick valley die frühen test
daten erlauben es uns licht aus dem
bereich sehr nah am schwarzen loch zu
sehen viel näher als jemals zuvor sie
zeigen uns dass die helligkeit dieses
ereignisses sehr gleichmäßig und ohne
stärkeres flackern zunimmt
ein äußerst ungewöhnliches verhalten das
so noch nie zuvor beobachtet werden
konnte doch es gab weitere
überraschungen
die betreffen die temperatur denn die
daten offenbaren dass diese kurz nach
beginn des ereignisses um fast die
hälfte abnehmen und zwar von 40.000 grad
auf nur noch 20.000 grad doch dies war
nur für eine kurze zeit der fall denn
kurz danach stabilisierte sich die
temperaturen wieder bis zum höhepunkt
steht die ehrlichkeit gleichmäßig an
überrascht waren die astronomie teams
auch von der strahlung freigesetzt wurde
denn hierbei handelte es sich um eine
eher geringe menge an energiereiche
röntgenstrahlung vergleichsweise konnte
aber enorm viel uv licht registriert
werden doch wie lässt sich diese
beobachtungen erklären
schließlich werden beim zerreißen eines
sterns oft gewaltige mengen an energie
frei das forschungsteam hält es für
möglich dass dies mit dem jet des
schwarzen lochs begründet werden kann
der von uns weg zeigt und somit für uns
kaum sichtbar ist er nehme
dementsprechend einen
ersten teil der energie auf und schießt
sie in richtung der drehachse des lochs
in den weltraum diese beobachtungen des
spektakulären sternen todes markieren
nach ansicht der experten experten einen
durchbruch in diesem forschungsbereich
die fachleute feiern ihren erfolg und
schreiben in der aktuellen studie es in
19 bt ist ein aushängeschild für eine
neue ära von studien früher teile des
raschen events kann man einem schwarzen
loch entkommen anklicken anschauen und
neugier zone abonnieren mega kanal bis
dann bleibt dran